welcome back President Biden student
loan bailout turning into a total
debacle The Legal fight now headed to
the Supreme Court but remember when the
big guy bribed voters and said the cash
Hannah was just weeks away remember this
we're gonna win that case I think in the
next two weeks you're going to see those
checks going out that's 16 million
people
who will be hearing from the Department
of Education that they've been approved
and who should be seeing relief in the
coming days
yeah they should be but it's pretty much
an illegal cash grab that was back in
November it is now December and the
president hasn't paid up yet and the
Supreme Court will take up this case in
February which means we likely won't
know their decision until next June but
the bite Administration not waiting his
education secretary has begun notifying
student loan borrowers that they are
approved for up to twenty thousand
dollars in University party cash but
he's gonna have to take that one back
um so Harold my big issue with this is
that it is turned into this political
debate as to whether or not the
government owes you a college education
so Elizabeth Warren is going after
Republicans why don't we go after these
colleges and universities who are making
college so expensive and keep raising
tuition prices without giving us more
professors more learning I agree with
you 100 so the Supreme Court's going to
talk here are going to speak here and
they will they will resolve this this
matter we'll all have to follow follow
what they say first and the question is
whether or not he has administrative
authority to do this he being will say
she one day but without the president
has the authority to do it and the judge
doesn't think so I actually happen to
think that the president has the
authority to do it but I don't like what
they did because I think what you're
saying is the more important thing first
of all we should prioritize what we're
going to if we're going to forgive debt
for some kids the professions and the
kinds of things we need more people
doing and as well we need to incentivize
people going into certain things and two
you raise the most important point we'll
come back and do this every three to
five to seven to ten years because
colleges are raising these tuitions I
don't know what kids and what families
and more importantly what the overall
Society is getting when you double
tuition over three or four years are we
healthier Are we more productive are we
producing uh better kids we're producing
better citizens smart assistants I don't
think that is the case so if I were the
president again I would convene the
presidents of these universities by the
way I like Halibut too I would say being
the presidents of these universities
private and public alike and say what
are you doing what are the upward
pressures and what can we do to contain
them because ultimately we as taxpayers
are the ones not only paying the tuition
but we're also paying for the fact that
we're not producing graduates who are
taking the jobs taking it Taking the the
risk that we need as a society and as a
country to succeed going forward so I
agree with you yeah and it's affecting
their lives because if they owe this
much in student loan debt that means
they're having to put off other major
life decisions that means depopulation
judge uh but but let's go to some of
these we'll bring in the illegal
self-populate that's what they want
really yeah they said that you know any
hot ones yeah
JK okay okay but judge this is there are
two lawsuits that are happening
concurrently and and that is sort of
what's fast tracking it to the Supreme
Court right what what do we expect to
see from the Supreme Court how could
they rule on this all right the fifth
and eighth circuits um have made a
decision that you know they're going to
pause and they're blocking the the
movement of the money and the Supreme
Court of course scheduled to hear as you
say in February we'll hear in June and
they are blocking any issue influence of
any money and and Joe Biden is clueless
so he's saying the money's coming the
money's coming but he I don't think he
has any idea
um a lot of the lawsuits we talked about
this before Harold the Republican
lawsuits were dismissed for lack of
standing the Supreme Court now believes
that in Missouri because Missouri has uh
the uh the Missouri higher education
loan Authority that funds most colleges
are an incredible amount of money that
they do have the standing the issue is
whether the 2003 Heroes act which was
meant for the military in the beginning
uh is available to people and to to
forgive student loans it makes no sense
to me we're no longer in an emergency
and you know what if you want to give
money away make it across the board give
it to senior citizens who are in a fixed
income who can't afford the inflation
all right give it to people who bought
an F-150 as Dana always talks about a
truck to start a company you know I
think that the Supreme Court is going to
say it's not an emergency and they're
going to say you do not have the power
of the purse Congress does Mr President
so shut up and you're not getting the
money I wonder if they're actually going
to write that down in the decision shut
up so uh Jim I think about you with the
story because you were a self-made man
you were also one of the most uneducated
people I know
successful Community College dropouts
beyond the hook with this tax to pay for
other people's bad College decisions no
it's a scam when I was sitting in my
classroom uh next to a 35 year old man
who was in a high chair and we were
playing Xbox in the community college
I did apply myself and make my way uh
this is a scam you know what it's like
it's like Obamacare in that the name
doesn't address the issue the Affordable
Care Act drove up premiums to the point
that our co-pays got so high I had to
crash my car because my car insurance
deductible was better than my Cadillac
planned payment but it's so stupid
because what happened here is they
didn't forgive loans as we know they
didn't address the issue they're just
passing the bill on to everybody else
but the judges are in a bad spot because
they do pressure Supreme Court judges
now and it's worse than ever because a
lot of these kids have already spent the
money on new scooters and cars so
they'll go right to the judge's house if
this gets overturned which I'm against
okay but the one thing I never you know
really got mad about when they were
doing the Roe versus Wade protests is
yeah they shouldn't be outside of
Justice's home but a lot of those women
needed the exercise
oh my garden they knew this was a loser
President Biden knew that he could wave
his little wand and it was really just
symbolic wasn't it and now he's running
on the Republicans are trying to block
my bribes
that's true and bribe's work if Judge
Jeanine was to take off her diamond
necklace right now and give it to me I
would do just about anything really and
if she was to throw in the diamond rings
I'd do it twice that's how effective
bribes work he likes halibut too
and now bribes are the Cornerstone of
the democratic party I mean you got
welfare foreign aid free college
earmarks those are bribes but you know
what they do Kennedy they call them
relief well I think we need some relief
from the bribes because that's our money
and we're going to go broke from all
these bribes absolutely right we need to
make the government smaller taxation is
theft we need to get the government out
of higher education and we need more of
the five which is coming up in moments I
went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now